large is a free-form canvas that serves
as a
for tool for electronic whiteboards and
tablets using
interaction
it's unique contribution is a continuous
free-flowing style of interaction
through unification of scope action and
zoom
to indicate scope the content creator
just frames part of the canvas with
their non-preferred hand
civ oaks the zoom catcher which
illuminates an area for selection in an
extremely lightweight manner the user
can then act on the strokes such as to
recognize
areas the user wants and only when the
user chooses to do so
the zoom catcher revealed itself by
piggybacking on a familiar gesture
pinch-to-zoom and as a result it's
largely self-explanatory
the user can grab things right away or
adjust the angle cast it in different
directions and fine-tune its extent if
necessary
it's coexistence with zoom allows
objects large and small to be brought
within reach
by making indication of scope fast
simple and clean.the zoom catcher sets
the stage for action commands appear at
hand
locally alongside the selection
for example the user can go up one
semantic level and recognize as well as
unrecognized ink or even drop down a
level and work with the stroke points
moves shift between flexible and
reversible representations
dropping images to the pixel level
allows blending with the finger rubbing
away with the eraser or cutting parts of
the image away with the pen
these flexible representations comprise
four axes of movement in the menus
addition to semantic levels there are
structural levels moving between
freeform layout and organized grids
temporal levels which allows select
strokes to be locally unstuck in time as
well as social levels which allow
pulling in inspirations from others by
searching the web as well as sharing
between tablet and whiteboard
taken together these axes of movement
scoped easily to specific portions of
the canvas give the user rich ways to
reinterpret and reflect in action with
their content
this opens up scenarios such as
sketching on a table
recognized when the user chooses to move
up a semantic level
just as easily drop down a level to
modify the underlying strokes
back up re recognizes it
and the user may continue to work in
this representation if desired
lists offer another example they exist
only as Inc never recognized unless the
user moves up a semantic level
or they can be elevated to checkboxes
drop back down to ink
edited through markup
and then Ari recognized now as diagram
nodes with labels
one level along the structural axis
groups them
and moving up one level more places them
in a grid
strokes within snap to grid as well
the zoom catcher integrates several
other capabilities
and drag through the context menu to
create and place a duplicate
or bring selections into the fold of
their palm by stroking through another
menu
this fold serves as a clipboard at hand
to conveniently transport objects far
away
and the zoom catcher itself acts as an
input filter and non-preferred hand mode
switch allowing pen gestures such as
lasso refinement of the selection
the user can organize even entire
canvases into new storyboards
you
or rework ideas from previous boards by
overlaying them and transferring content
to the current campus
you
taken as a whole these techniques open
new vistas for freeform content on
electronic whiteboards and tablets
in a unique way that affords unified
scope action and zoom
postage
both hands in natural and complementary
roles